[موسيقى]
سني او شيعي كلاهما يقول اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا رسول الله سني او
شيعي كلاهما يؤمن باركان الاسلام الخمسه
سني او شيعي كلاهما مسلم اذا لما يقال ان
للشيعه مصحفا خاصا بهم لما يقال انهم لا
يؤمنون بنبوه محمد هل يقدسون فعلا عليا
لماذا تروج صور غريبه على الشيعه لدرجه ان
البعض يعتقدوا ان للشيعي
ذيلا المسلمون الشيعه من هم ما هي
معتقداتهم هل يخفون فعلا ما يضمرون وما هي
حقيقه خلافهم مع اهل السنه اسئله طرحناها
على المواطن العربي في دول يغيب عنها
المذهب الشيعي في فلك الممنوع شاهدوا
معي قيل لنا اننا مختلفون وتعلمنا ان نكره
بعضنا
البعض فاذا كان لابد من
الصدام على الاقل دعونا يتعرف كل منا على
الاخر الاختلاف والتشابه السنه والشيعه
الشيعه
والسنه انا بالنسبه الي الشيعه يعني انا
اللي اسمعوا اسمي بس يعني معاويه يعني
يمكن اطول القتل لانه النسبه لمعاويه
سفيان يعني بيكره شي اسمه صحابه الشيعه
دول هم يعني ما بونيش بابو بكر وسيدنا
محمد قولوا اشهد ان علي ولي
الله صحابه الرسول بين عدول وبشر عاديين
يصيبون
ويخطئون ما بيؤمنوا بسيدنا محمد عليه
الصلاه والسلام بيقولوا سيدنا علي هو
النبي يمشي في مخهم وانه فهمتني جبريل
استغفر الله العظيم فهمتني غلطت في
الرساله فهمتني يبعثها لعلي و جات لسيدنا
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم هم انصار سيدنا
علي كانوا بيام منوا ان ان الوحي ما نزل
على الرسول سيدنا محمد بالخطا والمفروض
ينزل على سيدنا علي ماهمش متيقنين انه
الرساله هبطه على سيدنا محمد
الخلافه بين الاعتراف بكافه الخلفاء
والاعتقاد باحقيه علي بن ابي طالب طقوس م
الدينيه غير عن الطقوس الاسلاميه خالص
يعني طقوس خاصه يعملوها البكاء وال وحتى
الجلد في منهم مسلمين يعني هم طوايف
الشيعه ياسر دخلوا في متهات ودنسوا الدين
الاسلامي بشكل غريب وهم مش معترفين بالكتب
بكتاب القران ب يعترفوا بنا نحن بعتبر من
الكفار هما والخوارج اللي خرجوا على الدين
الاسلامي السني ونحن ك عقيده اهل سنه
والجماعه نخالف الشيعه بما يقومون به نقاط
التشابه بين السنه والشيعه الاعتراف
بالاخر كمسلم والاعتراف بمكه كقبول للصلاه
والاعتراف باركان الاسلام
الخمسه الصلوات خمس جمعها مباح عند السنه
استثناء و عند شيعه
مطلقا هم من الخوارج يعني ما بقدرش اقول
كفار حدش بيقدر يكفر مسلم ثانيا احنا كشعب
او كافراد مسلمين بنعرف انه من قال لا اله
الا الله او من شهد لا اله الا الله فقد
اسلم نورمي مع يرجع عرب
مسلمين السنه والشيعه يعتقدون بان القران
هو الكتاب المقدس وان محمدا هو خاتم
الانبياء دكتور بش جواد الباحث ومؤلف كتاب
المساله الشيعيه رؤيا فرنسيه نطلب منك في
بدايه هذا العدد تعريفا موضوعيا وبسيطا
ومختصرا اليوم اكثر من 40 مليون مسلم شيعي
من هم هؤلاء
الشيعه الشيعه هم من يعتقد من الناحيه
السياسيه بدءا وبعدين اصبحت ناحيه فقهيه
من يعتقد باحقيه الامام علي بن ابي طالب
صهر الرسول وابن عمه وزوج ابنته
فاطمه احقيته بالولايه او بالخلافه هم
مسلمون هم مسلمون 100 بال لا يختلفون عن
اي مسلم اخر منذ البدايه الى اليوم هناك
اختلافات فقهيه جاءت فيما بعد يعني يعني
اليوم اهل السنه والشيعه يعترفون ان
الشيعه هم من المسلمين بالضبط يعني مصدرهم
واحد كتابهم واحد نبيهم واحد وا
معتقداتهم واحده الفرق هو في خلاف سياسي
فرق سياسي من سيخلف النبي محمد بعد وفاته
سنتحدث في التفاصيل بعد قليل دعونا
مشاهدينا نتحول الى الرباط لنتعرف على
تجربه ادريس هاني كاتب وباحث مغربي تحول
من السنه الى الشيعه ادريس هاني ما هي قصه
هذا التحول باختصار
ولماذا تحيه طيبه لك ولضيوفك
المحترمين واشكرك على هذا التقديم لانه
تقديم فيه من الحكمه والعقل والدرايه لكن
بالفعل شيء مؤلم حينما
نستصعب لا لا يميزون حتى بين
ابجديات علم الكلام البسيط فهذه قضيه
كبيره جدا ويجب ان يب قت فيها العلماء
والمحققون بالنسبه الى التجربه حتى اكون
اختصر
الطريق انا لا اعتبر
نفسي تحولت بهذا المعنى وانما انا كنت
دائما اشعر بانني داخل العالم الاسلامي
وان كل هذه المدارس والمذاهب
والافكار هي راس مال رمزي لهذه الامه ومن
حق كل انسان ان ان يذهب ويعود حيث ما شاء
لانها كل افكار اسلاميه فانا اتجول في هذه
الحديقه الاسلاميه الواسعه وابحث عما يليق
بي وما يمكنني من خلاله ان ان استفز عقلي
وانسانيته و ما ارتاح واطمئن اليه سيدرس ق
قرات كتب عن الشيعه يبدو انك قرات كتب عن
الشيعه وتاثرت كثيرا بقصه الحسين
وبكلا ايوه نعم نعم ربما هذا مفتاح جعلني
اعيد مساءله التاريخ فقط فشيء الذي وردته
هو ان التاريخ مقدس ودين لكن ا قضيه
الحسين لم اهضم حقيقه واثرت
في مما
جعلني ادخل في تجربه مسائله هذا التاريخ
ومحاوله الوقوف عند هذه التفاصيل بكل ا
يعني بعيدا عن كل خلفيه يعني لم تكن عندي
خلفيه ولم اكن اعرف هذه المصائب والمشاكل
الطائفيه لم اكن اعرفها في ذلك الوقت طيب
فاعتبرت ان هذا حدث في التاريخ الاسلامي
ويجب انعم افكر فيه كونك اليوم شيعي يعني
هل تعتبر انك على
حق انا اولا يجب ان يفهمني من ينم طوني
لان للاسف الذين ينم طوني هم اقل درايه
مني في التاريخ وعلم الكلام انا لم اقول
انني بهذا المعنى لا هذه كلها مجرد
اختزالات وتنميط للاسف الغرض منها معروف
انا في نظري اعتبر اولا انا رجل اؤن بنسبي
الافكار نعم وثانيا انا اعتبر نفسي مسلم
على طول يعني انا مسلم فقط
وعندي ان قضيه السنه هي قيمه ا في الاسلام
والشيعه قيمه في الاسلام لان هذا بموجب
التفكير السني نفسه انه وجب ان نتبع السنه
سنه الرسول وايضا وجب ان نتشي لاهل البيت
ونصرهم فكلاهما
موجودان ولكن التحقيق هو في تفاصيل معينه
لذلك ما عندناش بديل عن عن
عن عن الاسلام فالاسلام سيظل هو الهدف وهو
الغايه يعني انت مسلم اولا انت مسلم اولا
وشيعي ثانيا شيعي المذهب طيب اليوم شيعي
وسني ايضا لانه ما فيش احد يستطيع ان
يزايد علي في انني عمقت علاقتي بالرسول
صلى الله عليهه من خلال تعميق لولاء لاهل
البيت طيب وصلت الفكره اليوم الشيعه في
المغرب انت مغربي حركه التشيع في المغرب
انتم متهمون بانكم يعني تعملون لصالح
الفرس لصالح ايران هل هذا حقيقي
نعم يعني اساسا انا تجربتي قبل ان اعرف كل
هذه الامور هذه تجربتي على فكره لها اكثر
من 30 عام يعني انا كنت صغير فبالتالي
الان فاقوا متاخرين وحاولوا يلبسوا علي
باثر رجعي كل امراضهم التي لها معروف من
وراءها فانتم تعلمين انه مثلا اذا خليني
اسمي الاشياء باسمائها هناك مشكله فقط
بالنسبه للتيار الوهابي الذي له موقف
تكفيري من كل من خالفه بمن فيهم السنه
والان دخل في اطار التدليس ويحاول ان يركب
صور نمطيه ومنها مثلا منها مثلا اذا جاء
احد مثلا لنفترض من الشيعه وا اصبح سنيا
فهم يعتبرون ان هذا حق وانه صادر عن علم
وصادر عن حكمه وصادر عن كذا و ولا يعتبرون
ان
هذا ايران ايضا تلعب الدور نفس تقريبا
يعني فيما يتعلق بالسنه الذين يتحولون الى
الشيعه ما ما الذي تفعله ايران بالنسبه
الي شخصيا خليني انا شاهد مثلا ما الذي
فعلته ايران بالنسبه الي فانا هذه
التساؤلات كانت وانا صغير يعني الي شيعي
بمعزل عن ايران انت اليوم شيعي مسلم شيعي
لانك اخترت نعم تفضل انا مسلم انا مسلم
مسلم ولست متم هبا بالمعنى الذي يراد منه
يعني بالمعنى الطائفي ليس كذلك انا مسلم
وامن بحق جميع المذاهب الاسلاميه في ان
ترسو على قاعده مشتركه حده انا ليس هذا
مزايده في ليس مزايده لانه هم عندهم كل
شهات للمذاهب انه تكون هنا وتخرج من هناك
طيب هذه التنميطات انا بعرف من وراءها طيب
اللاسف نحن وصلت الفكره سننتقل الان الى
تجربه في الاتجاه الم عاكس حسين مؤيد عالم
دين عراقي ترك المذهب الشيعي واعتنق السنه
هو معنا عبر الاقمار الصناعيه من جده
السعوديه شيخ حسين ما هو سر هذا
التحول بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في البدايه
اود ان اشكر لكم استضافتكم ودعوتكم
الكريمه
و اشكر لكم ايضا هذا التناول لموضوع حساس
ومهم جدا نعم وهو من المواضيع التي تلح
على العقل العربي والمسلم نعم ومن
المواضيع المطروحه التي تتفاعل على عده
اصعده ا في الحقيقه انا في البدايه اود اي
ان اسجل ملاحظه على التعريف الذي ذكره
الاستاذ
بشاره
لتشيع للتشيع
والشيعه ف هو تعريف الحقيقه لا اعتقد انه
يعبر
عن حقيقه
التشيع يجب ان نميز بين عده مستويات من
التشيع هناك التشيع الروحي وهناك التشيع
السياسي وهناك التشيع المذهبي التشيع
الروحي لا ينطوي على الايمان بالمفاهيم
التي يتبناها منظرو التشيع المذهبي وانما
هو حاله من الولاء
والموده
الخاصه لبعض من من لبعض من اهل البيت او
لمجموع اهل البيت ف هذا هذا الولاء عباره
عن
حاله
روحيه يمكن ان تنعكس سلوكيا على مستوى
احترام معين على مستوى توقير معين
واما التشيع
السياسي فهو طبعا غير موجود حاليا وانما
وجد في فترات معينه من التاريخ
الاسلامي وهو ايضا لا ينطوي على معنى
عقائدي ولا يعبر عن اتجاه ايديولوجي وانما
كان يعبر عن موقف سياسي
يناصر ال البيت او بعضا من من ال البيت
نعم ما اختلفت المواقف بينهم وبين غيرهم
فهذا
تشيع كان موجودا في بعض الفترات التاريخيه
المتقدمه وهو لا يعبر عن اتجاه ايديولوجي
واما لو سمحتي لكي تكتمل الفكره واما
التشيع التشيع الذي هو محل
البحث هو ما اصطلح عليه بالتشيع المذهبي
اها وهو الذي يعبر عن اتجاه ايديولوجي وعن
منظومه فكريه عقائديه
وفقهه
وتعاليم وهذا هو الذي يقع فيه
الاشكاليه ذلك اننا يجب ان نلتفت الى موقع
هذه المنظومه الفكريه وهذا الاتجاه
الايديولوجي الى موقع هذه المنظومه
من من ثقافه الامه
المسلمه ف من الواضح جدا اليوم الناس تهتم
اكثر وتسال اكثر عنك انت اليوم تركت
الشيعه وذهبت الى السنه لماذا نود ان نعرف
لماذا هذا الامر لم ياتي اعتباطا و انما
جاء بعد مراجعه فكريه معمقه استغرقت سنوات
من البحث والتحقيق والمقارنه بين
المدرستين
وتوصلت الى نتائج علميه
حاسمه ادت بي الى ان اترك التشيع المذهبي
فانا احتفظ بالموده لال البيت كما يحتفظ
بها وكما يشعر بها كل مسلم على
اختلاف
انتماءاته لكن تركت التشيع المذهبي تركت
التشيع كاتجاه ايديولوجي بعد ان ثبت لي ان
الاسس التي يقوم عليها التشيع المذهبي هي
اسس غير صحيحه وغير سليمه وثبت لي ان
التشيع المذهبي لم يكن سوى انشقاق عن
عقيده الامه وعن جماعتها وانا ارجو ان ان
تعطيني فرصه لتوضيح هذه الفكره لانها مهمه
جدا في في معرفه هذا الموضوع نعم باختصار
اي الامه الاسلاميه قبل بعثه النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم لم يكن لها وجود وانما هذه
امه وجدت من خلال ايمانها برساله النبي
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وهي امه عبر عنها
القران بانها اخرجت للناس طيب واخراجها
الناس يعني انها اخرجت بهويتها وثقافتها
التي تكتسبها من المصدرين الاساسين لها
وهما القران الكريم وسنه النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم ط وبالتالي تشكلت هويه الامه
وثقافتها في عهد النبوه على هذا الاساس
طيب يعني سواء من الناحيه العقائديه او او
من ناحيه المفاهيم والتعاليم الاخرى وقد
و الاوم اليوم فقط يعني السنه هم على حق
ام الشيعه هم على حق
برايك لا انا انا برايي ان السنه هم
القادرون على ان يمثلوا الاسلام الحقيقي
وهم التعبير الصحيح عن المضمون الديني
والرساله للاسلام
واما التشيع المذهبي كاتجاه ايديولوجي
ابقى معنا بعد الفاصل الاخباري ننقل لكم
مشاهدينا تجربه سني متزوج بشيعي كيف
يمارسان طقوسه ما الدينيه في حياتهما
اليوميه وايضا سيكون معنا من بيروت الباحث
والعالم شعي جعفر فضل الله ومن القاهره
الشيخ وليد اسماعيل في فلك الممنوع نلتقي
بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل